[Applaudissements]
ah bonjour alors en face deux rangs plus
merveilleux et tu la cnil à qui faire
sans la paix a dit que ça c'est vrai
c'est vrai ce lieu est très belle alyssa
le coup de mieux cerner du bien sauf
s'il tombe le un meilleur boulot c'est
double salto n'est pas d'accord ça fait
mal c'est dur c'est est daltonien
je me vois quelques mois allez-vous y
avait une question tout de suite bonjour
je m'appelle esther comme l'émission se
termine bientôt
je voulais savoir si certains
chroniqueurs comptaient partir en
vacances ensemble
et si oui est ce dans un cadre amical ou
juste pour faire l'amour c'est une très
bonne question que vous posez la
listeria la poche tous je ne pense pas
qu'il ya beaucoup plus de demandes pour
kelly que pour jean michel mr vers
théorie non il n'y aura pas de départ
commun je crois même au contrat qu'il
vaut mieux que tout le monde prenne de
la distance cet été 40 en cette fin
d'année plus personne ne peut
s'inquiéter si ça passe six millions
north bay à l'antenne ya encore des
sourires mais pendant les magnétos c'est
une catastrophe qui s'est passé voilà
par exemple ont diffusé un sujet pendant
un débat qui opposait burger quiz a
strike et j'ai l'impression que matthieu
delormeau et benjamin avait disons
quelques divergences d'opinion une
petite partie
qu une petite peinture contient du
mistral pour être
bon si c'est de maquereaux au vin de
merde l'histoire jean-luc se bat avec
bailly les parties savaient pas où ils
allaient rêve
il est parti c'était les deux segments
on y va tous on verra bien on valoir à
novare et il est arrivé sur le fln jean
n'a pas pris chez lui quand tu sais plus
quoi faire tu dis il va finir dans ton
cul c'est toujours une chute communauté
universelle les gens découvrent quelle
vulgarité batwa pas du tout à ces dames
de rothschild s'étend du lait c'est
normal car qui dit fin d'année dit aussi
négociations à la saison suivante je
vais vous faire une révélation
suite au départ de julien courbet
mathieu ce serait bien venu animer une
émission à sa mesure je donne juste et
initial cqdm levé c'est que de la
boucherie alors heureusement le projet a
été retoqué par seal qui selon la rumeur
on en parlera tout à l'heure aurait
préféré confier la suite de ces que de
la télé à valérie bénaïm mais ça va zéro
amertume chez mr
dans sa plainte
[Musique]
l'annexé
regardez moi rire
et c'est vrai qu'elle est prétentieuse
ou pas alors à la chance est pas la
changer
moi ça on le voit la belle elle a le
droit et si latif ai parlé tout à
l'heure nous irrite vous en pensez de
bena benhaim une idée oui je devienne il
est alors ça c'est la première phase de
la méthode de l'ormeau culpabiliser son
adversaire en face d'eux il est beaucoup
plus direct il annonce le programme à
venir
une éternité
les plus
ok
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'atlas à la casse à longueuil
pourquoi marianne métissée sa signature
mais je veux quand il a plus d'arguments
il en tout le monde est fait
affectueusement donc c'est sympa
dire qu'il ya nos sujets qui tend à peu
les chroniques et en cette fin de saison
les conseils de la hausse alors je vous
rappelle le concept deux fois par an
tous les chroniqueurs sont jugés par
leurs collègues
et quand rachid arhab samba on arrête la
séquence
rachid arhab s'en va on a des séquences
oiseaux finalement c'était pas une bonne
idée c'est quoi sa réputation l'aï dit
tout non là des roulades on sait
toutefois que la logique c'est bon il ya
eu un conseil de classe et voilà mais
bon on l'embrassé le bon leur foi par
exient donc on arrêtait à ce moment là
mais là c'est la fin d'année donc si la
connexion se passe est moins grave quoi
ces deux classes ont été relancés quelle
belle idée dernière c'était celui
d'isabelle morini-bosc est-ce que vous
avez des petits secrets de fabrique à
quand je vous montre ce qui se cache
derrière les images diffusées à
l'antenne
vous comprenez bien les motivations
d'une personne autour de la table
je vous propose un petit secret
côté de ça j'ai beaucoup d'affection
pour toi et je suis content d'être à
côté de toi voilà lot à ma note 6 même
si c'est pas mal et sa démission
ma note 6 est ce que je vous ai demandé
de mettre une note
vous non la production oui dit la vérité
ou à vous on y croit on veut pas de
genre ah non je vous jure que non mais
je m'occupe alors vous pensez de telles
personnes j'adore 8
c'est pas drôle tout le monde mais des
bonnes notes mais trois s'il te plaît
c'est marine
ouais voilà vous mettez ce que dit la
vérité doit partir c'est vrai que pour
moi et me 9,5 me 3 c'est vrai ou pas ah
oui mais c'est pas ce côté horripilant
avec isabelle donc non mais bon non mais
c'est vrai j'aime bien mais j'avais
minutes pour de vrai et finalement j'ai
mis trois ils m'ont dit est ce que du
beurre et 3g une fois gentil du coup
j'ai cédé à 6 d'accord on négocie pour
maximum a pas poussé la concision le
pousse à mettre plus offensif
voilà mais non mais la conséquence est
que de faire un truc drôle voilà c'est
payé de second degré ont nommé des loges
pour faire et voilà j'ai une question
merde allez la main
manouchehr immédiat
alors oui c'est vrai que lui il aura pas
de conseils de classe et n'importe quoi
et vous allez le détail tout à l'heure
quand mathieu montrent tous ses doigts
ça fait 6 allez on passe au top et dans
ces petits moments embarrassants de tpm
s'il a pour une fois ça va bien commencé
puisque je vais montrer des compliments
qu'on est qui ont été faits dans
l'émission ouais vraiment d'ailleurs
petit conseil si vous voulez que votre
compliment soit crédible
soyez précis sur les noms qui me fait le
coup
[Musique]
donc voila moi j'aime beaucoup alain
chabat j'aime beaucoup le plus ailleurs
[Musique]
je te laisse la châtre confie je me sais
que je devais sécher alors julien
courbet j'aime j'aime pas
[Musique]
d
la mallet
ouais
écoutez le souffle du vent ses pieds de
ne pas comprendre le pourquoi des choses
et sur la faisant russe kalinka
[Musique]
c'est à dire que pourriez lâché dès
demain l'as mâcon but attendu revenant
sur six es8 d'abord on va pas attendu
demain
bassel ses pieds enfin on m'a proposé
une collaboration s'est joué après le
tournoi marc andré qui va retourner
faire du jet-ski plus vite que prévu
[Musique]
c'est vrai que je m'occupe en ce moment
ob cage
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
eux c'est poids de couette s'émeut c'est
prout prout enfin jean sur tous les
[Musique]
impacts il avait vu le truc de canne
magique petit break musical mais qui va
bon là quand même j'ai l'oeil
vous avez vu mathieu être approximatif
tout à l'heure sur charlotte gabris
alias charlotte gabris alors normalement
quand tu connais pas le nom de la
personne tu te fais petit mais non c'est
matthieu delormeau aux câpres et il a
tenu à faire des compliments à charlotte
[Musique]
si tu avais promis à dormir toujours je
sais les drôles sauver son chien puisque
michael bay la vwa n'est donc pas réglé
mais drôle
[Applaudissements]
deux mâles et de jarry ça vous dérange
et par le côté jradi très belle mais
elle y serait sympathique mais ce n'est
pas la reine de la barca non non bah
voilà c'est drôle aussi pensé que
j'étais là pour mon humour baba bois
pourri pour moi il était alors
voulez-vous encore ce matin en
interwiews est magnifique
après l'interview beinheim méfiez-vous
un cas beaucoup travaillé ensemble
l'année prochaine mais fier oui oui je
me mettais des semelles antidérapantes
on peut déraper fennecs très bien nos
miss c'est comme ça c'est mon frère
voilà alors jean approximations sur le
nom j'en ai une je garde de ce qu'il
entend
une approximation mais je les aime bien
celle à car c'est un bel hommage que
vous m'aviez rendu cyril oui tu te dis
que le mec s'intéresse bien ton travail
si on le laisse s'installer c'est qu'il
y sera donc le fait j'ai peur qu'il n'y
soit pas vous êtes debout à côté c'était
jean luc lemoine dans radio bistrot et
alors
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la soirée halloween a gelé depuis trois
mois à mai mais ça c'est méchant
l'abattement des sabbats radio bistrot
c'est anne roumanoff c'est mon bistrot
alors pour vous vous en souvenez une
bonne fois pour toutes et parce que ça
fait longtemps un nouveau petit bistrot
alors vous connaissez le principe je
ralentis mes camarades et du coup tout
le monde a l'air bourré vous allez voir
sur benjamin ça fait un peu ton sur ton
[Musique]
voici le seulement nous aurons c'est
parti juni il veut dit long sur mer et
brûlent sommaire et libanais vous moi
c'est pas gentil avec moi
le budget n'était pas présent la dent
donc peu dire la rediffusion sur la
réponse au mot la mamie parce que moi je
veux moi quoi vous avez la pause où elle
n'aimerait pas jouer c'est vrai c'est
vos affaires
c'est vrai qu'à gérer faire rire les
tours de famille un an je vais revenir
mon père parti l'a quitté je me ménage
pas pour ma femme sur leurs joues tu
meurs je saurai me suis alors si c'est
bon tu mon cochon jeu rien n'y a pas une
image
il restera si tu te dis non
ah ouais c'est vrai qu'ici
t'es bourré mon vieux
à
[Musique]
et on commence par jean michel maire ce
qui je vais faire un aveu ne sait jamais
avant les missions qui sont les invités
du jour c'est vrai alors quand il ya une
interrogation il regarde sur le
conducteur ce journal on recevait entre
autres le héros du xviiie arrondissement
vous vous souvenez ce garçon qui avait
secoué les derniers meubles pour sauver
un enfant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les gens pourront venir
personne
[Musique]
qu'attendez vous de ce vaisseau français
spéciale des bébés
vous êtes spécialiste de la comédie
alors il une attente
[Musique]
mais aussi des bougies
c'est comme en ce moment
j'adore le
[Applaudissements]
ces questions
si fribourg les poussant squatteurs
couchés tard
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'aime diriger
est ce que tu veux bien que le premier
invité de tmp de l'année prochaine aller
allons-y
c'était je peux signer
[Applaudissements]
mais si ton bébé
je suis arrivé en même temps que toi il
ya maintenant un peu plus de vingt peu
moins de deux ans et je trouve que dans
ton sourire et à tous il ya des
souvenirs et des larmes mais la démo
hadji tout comme toi qui tu appelles
tonye tonye de lille également aussi
bill à deux heures de paris
vous venez me voir conservez-vous pour
sélectionner le mister france était pmp
chica chica gastambide bien sûr mon
frère voilà hexis ses plus hauts
[Musique]
et les pieds c'est combien l'envergure
des coups dans la gueule de brasser 2004
c'est vraiment toi tu 53 ans et plus je
peux rien dire
[Musique]
je ne peux pas faire plus